- Hi, good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Priya Natarajan.
I'm an astrophysicist
and serve as the current
director of the Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities at Yale.
I am delighted to invite you all
to a monthly inference colloquium series.
Though first I would like to
recognize our benefactors,
Mr. And Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
who are on the call
today and have joined us.
And I also wanna remind all of you
that we are recording this event
and the recording is made
available within a week or so.
And since we are recording,
we are required to have all
participants mute their videos.
And if you wish to
participate in the Q and A,
which we encourage, we would
like you to submit questions
through the chat feature
and feel free to submit
your questions throughout.
Although we will handle the questions
and the speaker will address
them at the end of their talk.
So I am absolutely delighted
today to introduce our speaker,
Professor James Owen Weatherall,
who is a Professor of Logic
and Philosophy of Science
at the University of California Irvine.
But he's also a member
of the Institute for
Mathematical Behavioral Sciences
and Center for Cosmology.
And as you all know, part of the goal
for this series is to
really try to understand,
explore and understand issues related
to epistemic models,
correlation, causation
and we could not have a better speaker
than today's to provide deep insights
into what models really do.
And over his career, he has
looked at a range of questions.
Very, very interesting,
very topical questions.
His most recent book is
titled, The Misinformation Age,
How False Beliefs Spread,
and which is coauthored
with Cailin O'Connor
in which he sort of
explores the social dynamics
and this parent, if you will,
of belief in evidence rich environments.
And he has several previous books as well.
One on the void, which is the first one
of his that I actually read
and thoroughly enjoyed
that was published in 2016
by Yale University Press.
His current research
interests as I mentioned,
span a range of very, very
relevant issues that have to do
with mathematical and conceptual
foundations of physics,
philosophy of cosmology
and social epidemiology.
Today, he will be talking to us
about polarization of beliefs.
In particular on issues where at the gist,
life facts in contrast to opinions.
So one striking feature, as
you have all probably noted
of the current political
environment in the United States
and elsewhere is that
they're a large groups
of people with extremely divergent beliefs
about what are in fact
testable matters of fact.
So these are matters of fact,
whether it is a rich and
widely accessible body
of scientific evidence that
will clearly support one side
over the other.
And despite that, there
is a raging dispute.
And so, you know, we have
all seen this manifested
in the political environment,
with the elections
and the aftermath of the elections,
as well as the unfolding global pandemic
and all the public health
and medical issues that
have arisen around that.
And we have seen in
many ways, the you know,
in the context of the
provisional nature of science,
we've sort of seen this interplay
of the honing and refining
of facts and data and
evidence and belief formation.
We've all sort of had a front row seat
to how some of these processes occur,
especially in this past year.
In his talk today,
James will draw on recent modeling work
to provide three distinct
possible explanations
for this polarization in belief.
And each of these explanations invokes
very different mechanisms and
recommends different remedies.
He will conclude with a
discussion of what it means
from the perspective of epistemology
of a model based science
that such different models can produce
such similar outcomes.
And the moral of his talk
today will be to caution us
against very overly
simplistic explanations
and understand that these are
issues of great complexity.
And therefore, there are
no silver bullet solutions
to our current quandary, sort of living
in an environment which is
rampant with misinformation,
disinformation, and rampant
denial of scientific facts.
And I just wanna mention
that as for custom,
tomorrow we will host a conversation
between Professor Weatherall
and Professor Kevin Dorst
of the Department of Philosophy
from the University of
Pittsburgh and at the same time,
so may 26 tomorrow at 3:00 PM.
And so we are really, really
looking forward, James,
to your talk today, please take it away.
And thank you so much
to both of you for
accepting this invitation.
- Thank you so much Priya
and thank you for your work
in organizing the series.
I've enjoyed the other talks
and glad to get to participate.
So I'm gonna share a screen here.
Great, so just gonna jump right in.
I'm gonna talk today about polarization
and so let me just be clear right up front
what I mean by polarization
because there are a few different kinds
of phenomenon that arise in,
you know, in this context
that sometimes get this name.
So what I have in mind
when I talk about polarization
today is a situation
in which you have a community
of epistemic agents.
So by that, I mean a community
of people who are trying to
learn about how the world is.
And so polarization arises
in such a community
when the various members
of the community come to hold beliefs
that diverge from one another.
So I'm talking about
situations where agents come
to hold divergent beliefs
about matters of fact.
And I wanna be very
clear when I say belief,
I'm not talking about religious belief,
I'm not talking about assertions
about values, what matters,
whether something is important or not.
What I'm talking about are
credences about matters of fact.
So the amount of confidence that you have
that some assertion about
the world is true or false.
Now, polarization apparently obtains
in real world situations.
There are many examples just we've seen
in the last several years.
For instance, you pose the question,
was there widespread voter fraud.
Widespread is too fuzzy a word.
Was there voter fraud
at a scale sufficient
to influence the outcome
of the 2020 US election?
Considerable amounts of
polling data suggests
that there really is a divergent.
There really are divergent
beliefs in the US population
about that question with
a great deal of confidence
on both sides about what the facts are.
So this is the kind of
situation that I have in mind.
And I'm focusing here as Priya mentioned
in the introduction, on
cases where it's not just
that there are these
disagreements, but in fact,
there appears to be information available
to the community that bears
on the situation in the sense
that there should be evidence,
there's evidence available.
Prima facie, it appears
that that evidence ought
to be sufficient to settle the
issue one way or the other.
And yet, nonetheless,
it doesn't seem as if consensus emerges.
Okay, and so what I'm
gonna do today is talk
about three different models
in which polarization
is a possible outcome.
Is there are agent-based models
in which I will describe
how sort of very simplified setting,
idealized agents gather information
about the world and share that information
and then update their beliefs in light
of that information and show that
in each of these models,
polarization is a possible outcome.
Now, each of these
models can be understood
to suggest a prima facie
plausible explanation
of real-world polarization.
These are the kinds
of explanations that you
sometimes see theorized
as the explanation for actual
real-world polarization,
but as I'll discuss, each
of the models differs
in the kind of explanation that they offer
and in the details of the conditions
under which you should expect
polarization to appear.
And then, so you know, most
of the talk is gonna be
discussing these various models
and what kinds of explanations
of polarization they suggest.
But I'm gonna conclude
by thinking about some issues
and philosophy of modeling,
about what we can infer
from this situation.
What we can infer from the
fact that a single phenomenon,
a single social phenomenon,
in this case could be plausibly modeled
in such different ways.
I now acknowledge my a collaborator.
So I'm gonna be discussing
three different papers.
Two of which have appeared in print.
One of which is unpublished.
Cailin O'Connor is a co-author
on all of these papers.
Also co-author of the
book that Priya mentioned,
Misinformation Age,
where some of these results are discussed.
Okay, so we discussed the
modeling methodology briefly.
So, as I said, I'm gonna
discuss here agent-based models.
I wanna emphasize these are
highly idealized models.
These are not meant to
provide a fully accurate,
complete representation
of any kind of human activity.
They're supposed to abstract
some particular collection
of salient features that
one might ask whether,
one might ask
whether those features are sufficient
under some circumstances to bring
about some sort of qualitative phenomenon.
And so we're reasoning
with highly abstract and
highly idealized models.
I'm gonna describe how the models work,
so hopefully you'll get
a sense of how this works
but I just wanna flag
upfront that we aren't trying
to give various
similitudiness representations
of the actual, you
know, social world here.
We're doing something a little
bit different from that.
Two of the models that
I'm gonna discuss are
within the same modeling framework
known as the network
epistemology framework
and then the third considers
individual Bayesian learning.
Now each project establishes conditions
under which polarization may emerge.
Now, I absolutely do not wanna suggest
that these are the only
models in which this happens
or the most important models
in which this happens
or anything like that.
They're representative in a sense,
but I'm describing some of the
models that I've worked on.
There are many, many other
models, some very similar,
some very different
from the ones I'm gonna discuss that lead
to very similar sorts of
arguments and observations.
Okay, good.
So I'm gonna begin by
giving a sort of an overview
of the framework in which
the first two models lives,
the network, the epistemology framework.
I'm then going to introduce two versions,
two network epistemology
models that I'm gonna discuss.
One based on what I'm
gonna call trust dynamics,
one based on what I'm
gonna call conformity.
And then I'm gonna
introduce the third model,
works in a somewhat different framework
and discuss how that can be
used to understand some aspects
of journalistic practices.
And then I'm gonna
conclude with a discussion
of what we can learn from
this modeling situation.
So to begin, network of epistemology.
So to build the models
on the first two of
these parts of the talk,
we work in a framework that
was originally developed
by two economists, Venkatesh
Bala and Sanjeev Goyal.
They were working with an audience
of economists in mind,
but their work was adapted
to the philosophy of science
context about 15 years ago now
by Kevin Zollman who is the
one on the far left there.
So since then, there's been a community
of people working in philosophy
of science using this sort
of framework to try to
understand various aspects
of the social spread of evidence
and belief within epistemic communities,
generally and specifically
within scientific communities.
And so the way these models work is
that you have a decision problem.
So basically you're trying to choose
between two possible actions.
We're gonna call one action
A and the other one action B.
Now the setup here is that
action A and action B,
when they succeed,
provide the same payoff,
but they succeed at different rates.
And so you're uncertain
about which one has a
higher expected value
because you're uncertain
about which one's exceeds
at the higher rate.
So we're gonna assume here that
in fact one of these actions
has been well-studied
and all of the agents are confident
that that action is,
succeeds at a rate of 0.5.
So half the time it succeeds,
it gives payoff one,
half the time it fails
and it gives no payoff.
But they're uncertain about the rate
at which the other
action, action B succeeds.
And they're trying to learn
about whether actually B
has a higher expected value
or a lower expected value by testing.
They're performing, they
perform the various actions.
They learn based on what happens
when they do perform the actions.
They update their beliefs
about which action is better.
And so there's a whole
community trying to converge
to all act in the way that
yields the higher expected value.
Now, this is a very
simple problem of course.
There's certain kinds
of scientific situations that
have this qualitative feature.
So for instance, you might think
about a situation where a
new medication is introduced.
And if that medication succeeds,
it has the outcome that
a patient survives.
And if it fails, the
patient does not survive.
You're gonna have to, you know,
you're trying to compare now
is this new medication
more or less successful
than some existing medication
whose success rate is well-known.
One thing that's nice
about this particular kind
of example, is they're pretty high stakes.
So you wanna perform whatever action
you think is the better one,
even though you're of course,
very, very interested
in learning from others,
whether or not perhaps
the other action turns out
to be better after all.
Okay, and so this is the problem
that our agents are trying to solve.
We represent the agents
as having credences.
So these credences can be represented
as a single number between zero and one.
We can think of that as the
probability that the agent,
each agent assigns to the
proposition that B is better.
Now, I should say, in all of these models,
we're just adopting a convention
that in fact B is better.
This is important because there
really is a better outcome.
You know, there's a fact of the matter.
There's some truth here
that we can know about
outside the model and
which we can observe now
how the agents learn or
how successful they are
in learning about whether
or not B is in fact better.
Okay, and so the agents
are arranged on a network.
So the idea is that each agent
in each round of the
simulation is understood
to perform an action.
They perform the action
that they think is better
some number of times.
So if they're, the number
that represents their
credence is greater than 0.5,
they perform action B.
If it's less than 0.5,
they perform action A
some number of times.
After doing that,
you can think of this as a kind
of performing an experiment.
You get some sample and could be one,
but it could be greater than one.
So you could perform the
action several times,
think of that as the
results of an experiment.
And now you take that data
and each agent updates their belief
in light of that data using Bayes rule.
Okay, now in addition to
updating, based on their own data,
this is where the network
structure comes in.
This is why this is the
network of epistemology.
In addition to updating
their beliefs based
on their own data,
all of the agents also
update their beliefs based
on the data generated by
their immediate neighbors.
And so what happens here is that you have
at least to begin with, different agents
in the network performing
the two different actions,
but then in general,
all or many of the agents
receiving information
not only about what they
think is the better action,
but also what their neighbors
think is the better action.
And this way they can update
on both kinds of actions.
And eventually they converge
to some sort of outcome.
Now this basic model as I've
just described it is one
in which generally authors have found
that communities converge
towards consensus.
That is either all of the agents converge
to having very high
confidence that action B is
in fact better.
An outcome that we'll call true consensus.
So the consensus about the truth.
And the other possibility is
that the agents all erroneously settle
on the worst action, A.
But because of the
structure of this model,
you're gonna get one or the other.
So basically what's going
to happen is eventually all
of the agents are gonna
be performing action B,
which isn't backed better.
And overall the data is going
to tend to keep their beliefs
that B is better, high.
Or what's going to happen is that all
of them are gonna come to
believe that A is better,
no one will perform action B anymore.
And so you end up with a stable outcome
where no new information
about action B is gathered
because everyone has decided
that the worst action is better.
Okay, so that's the basic model
that we're gonna be working
with the first two parts of the talk here.
Now I'm going to discuss the
first of two modifications
to this model that
introduced some component
that might be understood
to explain polarization.
Okay, so this is based
on a paper that Cailin
and I wrote that was published
in the European Journal
for Philosophy of Science
a few years ago called
Scientific Polarization.
So in this model, what we do is we begin
with the same network
of epistemology model
that I discussed,
but we modify how agents update
in light of evidence
produced by other agents.
So agents still update in
light of their own evidence
in the same way, but they update
in light of other agents'
evidence in a different way.
The idea here that the
motivation for this is
that we suppose that agents
take some evidence to be
of higher quality than others.
And the higher quality evidence
they're going to take to,
they're gonna be very confident in.
Lower quality evidence, they're
going to be less confident.
So how do they determine what kind
of evidence to be confident in?
Well, of course there are various ways
in which you can imagine
are very complicated,
high rationality sorts of strategies
for figuring this out.
Here we suppose just a very simple one
which is that the agents
take the data generated
by people who disagree with
them to be less trustworthy.
Now, why would you do that?
So one idea here is
that if you're evaluating
someone's information,
the information that
somebody is sharing with you
and you think, okay, this
is an epistemic process.
They've somehow gathered this data.
I'd like to try to
evaluate how good they are
as epistemic agents, how
likely are they to come
to good conclusions, collect
data reliably and so on.
And I'm gonna use their
past epistemic success
by my own lights to evaluate that.
And so the idea is that
if I look around and I
see, well, these people,
according to the data
that I have access to
and the beliefs that I hold,
appear to have succeeded
in their epistemic tasks.
I'm gonna assume that
the data they're sharing
with me is more reliable.
And the people who by my own lights appear
to have failed at their epistemic tasks,
I'm gonna understand, do
likely be producing data
that's less reliable.
Now, I'm still gonna treat that data
in general as something I can update on,
but I'm going to treat it as less certain.
So here's the idea.
I am going to model trust here
as an assignment of uncertainty
to the amount, sorry,
assignment of uncertainty
to the data produced
by other agents where the amount
of uncertainty is described by
some function that decreases
with the distance between my beliefs
and the agent who's
produced the data's beliefs.
And so the idea here is that an agent who,
if someone produces evidence, that is,
if someone holds beliefs that
are very distant from mine
whatever evidence they produced,
I'm going to treat that
as a more uncertain than evidence produced
by someone who is closer
to my own beliefs.
Now, the updating rule that
we use here, I didn't write it
down on the slide, but it's
a standard updating rule,
an alternative to Bayes
rule for updating beliefs
in light of evidence known
as Jeffrey Conditionalization
which is a standard way
of updating beliefs in
light of uncertain evidence.
And so what's going on here is
we're treating evidence produced by others
as uncertain evidence with
some degree of uncertainty
that's determined by this function.
Now I'll just note that
this kind of strategy.
So using Jeffrey
Conditionalization to model this,
I believe his original to
this paper, but the basic kind
of strategy where you
conditionalize, how you,
how agents update their
beliefs or their opinions
based on some function of the
distance between their beliefs
or opinions is widespread
in the literature.
This is something that's been studied
at least since early 2000s
and so what we're doing is
adapting this kind of mechanism
to the network of epistemology framework
and introducing the idea
that Jeffrey Conditionalization
is a useful way of modeling.
Now, I'll just note
that we have to introduce
some decreasing function
of the distance between
agent's beliefs to do this.
We consider different ones,
just a linear function,
exponential and some others,
and the qualitative results
don't depend on that.
As long as it's a strictly
decreasing function,
we get qualitatively the same results
and the qualitative results
are really what we take
to be trustworthy here
or in any way, you know,
the relevant output of the model.
Okay, so what are the results of this?
Well, first there's a new possibility now.
And the new possibility
is that for certain values
of this parameter M which
governs how strongly agents tend
to distrust other agents,
we can begin to see polarization.
So when that parameter
exceeds a certain value,
conventionally set to one in
the model as we've set it up,
we see polarization,
which are stable outcomes
where some agents have high
credence that B is better.
And some have low
I.e. they believe that A is better
and more over it's stable
because the agents
don't trust one another.
They've come to occupy,
to be distanced enough
from one another in belief
space that the agents
that are performing action
B and producing evidence
that the better action is in fact better,
no longer influence the agents who believe
that agent, that action A is better.
Right, and so what happens is
although lots of evidence
is being produced
and lots of evidence is being shared,
you've gotten to a situation
where the agents are so distant
from one another, that they
don't trust one another
and they don't update
in light of the evidence
that's shared by the other group.
And one way of thinking
about what happens here is
as M becomes larger and
larger, the distance
in belief that needs to be
achieved in order for this,
for failure of listening to
occur, gets smaller and smaller.
And so the idea is that you know,
there's some parameter here
that's going to govern how that works.
And so here's a chart that showed
how that happens in the model.
As I said before, M equals
one is conventionally set
as the value of the parameter
for which is even possible
for them to stop listening
to one another, as opposed
to merely treating each other's
evidence as very uncertain,
but still updating on it.
And so, as you see, as M gets larger,
various sizes of networks.
What we see is that polarization
becomes increasingly likely
and once M gets up to two
or a little bit higher,
you begin to see polarization
in all, or nearly all runs.
Okay, good.
Just note that it's not just that,
this parameter M doesn't
just increase polarization,
it also increases the total number
of false beliefs that are
held by the community.
And so what you see here are
plots of average outcomes
across a large range of
different parameter values,
different values of N,
different values of the number
of agents in the network.
And so on, different values of Epsilon,
how hard a problem it is,
how big is the difference
in expectation value between
action A and action B.
And what you see is across all
of those different
parameters, as M increases,
the fraction of the network
that ends up holding
false beliefs increases.
And so you're gonna see
different fractions depending
on the different other parameters,
but each of these lines is
higher than the one before it.
Okay, so there's lots more that
I could say about this model
but the point is to
describe several models.
So let me move on and just
point to some of the takeaways
from this model that are
going to be important
in discussion that follows.
So I think the first takeaway is
just that polarization
can apparently occur
under these sorts of circumstances.
That is, it can occur in
an epistemic community
with certain kinds of properties
in which agents tend to
distrust evidence produced
by some agents where that
distrust is conditioned
on their difference in beliefs.
Now in the present model,
the phenomenon is driven
by the fact that agents explore,
i.e. perform the action
that they think is better.
And so it's the people
who believe B is better
who are performing action B
who are generating data about action B.
And it's precisely those
agents that are ignored by
or distrusted by the ones
who hold the false belief.
The ones who think that
action A is better.
And so what's happening here is
that distrust is preventing
the reliable information
from reaching the people who would need it
to reach more reliable beliefs.
And so you might think of this
as possibly a way of
modeling certain kinds of,
certain kinds of vaccine hesitancy
where some people are,
believe that vaccines, let's
say a COVID vaccine is safe
and effective, other people
think it hasn't been shown
to be safe or it hasn't
been shown to be effective.
There's a lot of data now,
population level data,
hundreds of millions of
people across the world
who have received this vaccine.
Good data on what their
outcomes have been so far.
But if that data isn't trusted
by the people who are
skeptical for various reasons.
Maybe they think it's manipulated.
Maybe they think that people
are trying to mislead them
or have some ulterior motive.
They're not going to update their beliefs
in light of that data,
even though it's present.
So I just wanna say once again,
this is a particular model, but in fact,
this is consonant with a very
large literature discussing
especially what's sometimes
known as opinion dynamics
in the case where agents
condition how their beliefs change
on the distance between their belief
or their opinion and that of other agents.
So this is a widely studied phenomenon.
It's one common possible
explanation that you see
in the mathematical
social sciences literature
for how polarization might arise.
Okay, now I'm gonna switch gears.
We're gonna talk about another
network epistemology model.
One that invokes a different mechanism
to explain polarization which
I'm gonna call conformity.
Once again, this is based
on a paper that Cailin
and I wrote together.
Cailin doesn't like this paper as much as,
so she let me be first author on this one.
Okay, so conformity.
So there's a very long literature
in social psychology that,
experimental literature
that documents a tendency
of human subjects to conform
with members of their social group.
The Asch experiments in particular is one
where you have a subject
in a group where the other groups are
not experimental subjects,
but are members of the research team.
And what happens is the
whole group are shown
a number of pictures, right?
So you have a line
and then two other lines with
two or three other lines.
Anyway, you're shown a line,
you're shown some other lines
and you're asked, is this
first line the same length
as one of these other ones.
And the various research
group participants,
I mean, they're the ones
who are not subjects say
that something that's obviously false.
That, you know, this line which
is clearly the same length
as this other line is longer.
And then the research subject is asked
to give their opinion on this.
And you find that in a
significant number of cases,
they will go along with
the group, despite the fact
that just the evidence
of their senses, right?
The fact that it's obviously the case,
that the group has, you
know, the other members
of the group have
expressed some false view.
Okay, so given that tendency,
we may try to introduce conformity
into a network of epistemology
framework as follows.
So the idea here is that
when you're making a decision
about what action to perform,
you might be thinking
about the payoff you'll get
from performing that action,
but you might also be considering
some other preferences
that will enter
into an expected value calculation.
And so one such preference
might be a desire
to conform your actions to
the actions of your neighbors.
So we model this by adding
a conformity parameter
which tracks how much payoff actors get,
simply from matching their behaviors
to those of their network neighbors.
Now, we once again adopt a
very low rationality model here
where we aren't you know,
each agent isn't trying
to model the beliefs
or likely actions of the
other agents around them.
All they're doing is they're saying, well,
what did people do in the last round?
If most people did action
A, then I'm going to expect
to get a payoff from
conforming to action A
and in order to choose to do action B,
I need to not only believe
that action B is better,
but I also need it to be the case
that the benefits that I get by, you know,
the good feeling I get
by conforming all of my
neighbors doing action A has
to overcome the benefits
of performing action B.
And so the idea here is that we're going
to weigh two different desires.
A desire to choose accurate actions
and get the payoffs that come with that
and a desire to conform with neighbors.
Now, when we introduce
this, we once again,
like with the trust dynamics,
begin to see new possible
outcomes for the model.
So simulations can still
approach either true consensus
or false consensus.
Those are still possible outcomes,
but another possible
outcome that doesn't exist
in the base model is a situation
where the network may
converge to a situation
where everyone performs the same action,
even though some agents secretly believe
that the other action is better,
but they don't perform the other action
because they prefer to conform.
And because they don't
perform the other action,
no new evidence regarding the superiority
of the other action is
introduced into the network.
And so, although there are,
there's some diversity of
belief here, it's not reflected
in the data that's generated
and shared in the network.
And we call that situation.
We have two different names,
one is true disagreement
and false disagreements.
So true disagreement is a situation
where everyone's performing
the better action,
but there's disagreement still.
The other situation is
where everyone's performing
the worst action,
performing action A, even
though some people believe
that action B is better.
Now finally, we can find an outcome
where you get polarization
in action and beliefs.
So the idea here is that
under some circumstances,
specifically in the presence
of certain network structures,
what can happen is that
one group comes to believe
that action A is better, and
they all perform action A.
And another group comes to
believe that action B is better
and they all perform action B,
but the information
doesn't pass effectively
between the groups.
So to see how this depends
on network structure,
let me introduce a few
basic network structures.
So consider lots of different things.
The cycle, the wheel,
the complete network,
these are standard networks to consider.
They're not that important
for our purposes, the
ones that are important
for our purposes are what happens
when you have a randomly generated network
using various different kinds
of algorithms for generating
networks, or in particular,
you look at networks
that you might describe as
clumpy or having cliques.
So the idea here is that
polarization is going
to appear specifically
in cases where networks
have a clique structure.
So how does this work?
Well, the idea is if you have,
a clique here is defined as a group
of agents that are tightly
connected to one another,
but only weakly connected
to other groups of agents
who are in turn mutually tightly
connected to one another.
As we see in this case,
we have two separate,
complete networks that are
linked only by a single edge.
And so the way in which
polarization can appear here is
that in one of these cliques,
everyone comes to believe
actually B is better.
They perform action B and they,
that sort of mini network
approach as a true consensus.
Whereas in the other clique,
everyone comes to perform action A
and almost all of them believe
that action A is better.
But in fact, the one agent in
this picture who has access
to the information from the
other clique will generally
over time, come to update
on that information,
come to believe that in
fact, action B is better,
but because of their
preference to conform,
and there's only one action B doer
in their immediate network,
but there are many action A doers
in their immediate network.
They never switched their action,
but because they're a kind of
bridge for this information,
because they never switched their action,
the other agents in their clique
never received data showing
that action B is better.
So the picture is one
where that agent conforming
sort of blocks the spread
of reliable information into their clique.
And so you can see different
kinds of outcomes here
depending on how strong this
conformity parameter is.
Basically kind of informative parameter is
just a measure of how
strong the preference is
for conforming your actions
to those of your neighbors.
What'd you see is that, you know,
as conformity increases,
correct consensus still tends
to be more likely.
Correct disagreement is the
next most likely outcome.
And then you start seeing
these incorrect consensus
and incorrect disagreements,
but then you have this
very small likelihood here
of getting polarization,
but that, you know,
how big that likelihood is
depends on just what your
network structure is.
And so if we look
at specifically different
network structures,
we see different results.
So especially in the
case of high conformity,
which is the plot on the left
here, unless I'm mirrored,
in which case it's the part on the right,
the one that's labeled high conformity.
What you see is that in
the clumpy case, right?
This case with the
strong clique structure,
nearly half of all outcomes
are polarized outcomes.
And so if you have a network
that has that structure,
then you can expect
polarization to occur simply due
to conformity without needing
any other explanation.
So what can we take away from this?
Well, in the presence of
certain network structure,
conformity provides
another sufficient cause
for polarization.
And that's because of this mechanism
whereby you get
bottlenecks, as I described.
Now, if you're thinking,
well I mean, how realistic are these sorts
of clumpy networks?
Well, the answer is
that in fact, research,
empirical research on all sorts
of real human social networks
from the structure of Facebook networks
to studies of sort of ordinary
offline populations suggest
that real social networks
have a characteristic known
as a small world property,
which means that agents tend
to have few connections, but
to have a very short pathway
between them and anyone
else is sometimes called
the Kevin Bacon effect.
- James, are these also
referred to as bubbles?
Or is that slightly different?
- So that's slightly different.
This predates the idea of
filter bubbles by two decades.
Yeah, so this is just a general
result in network theory
that you can describe small world networks
and then it turns out
to be an empirical fact
that you have these sorts
of small world networks
in real situations where,
and they're called small worlds
because the small world
metaphor isn't supposed
to be one where you think we
have these isolated worlds
that are distinct from one another,
like little worlds, rather it's
the small world phenomenon.
Like who would have known
that you knew so, and so,
or that you were just two
or three connections away from so-and-so.
Now, I don't remember the number exactly,
but it's something like on
average, the average path lines
between random Facebook members is a very,
very low, it's like four or five.
And so, you know,
that the average path length
for information to spread
to anywhere in the network
is surprisingly short.
But the point is
that these small world networks
are ones that have cliques.
And if you, there's a standard algorithm
for generating small world networks,
generating random small world networks
and I'm just the Strogatz-Watts algorithm.
You use that algorithm
to generate your networks
and using random networks for
these conformity dynamics.
You find polarization
at a much higher rate
than in the other sort
of more uniform networks
that I introduced.
Okay, so this is another kind
of possible explanation for
polarization having to do
with the network structure
of human interaction.
Let me now introduce yet another model
with a totally different
framework and mechanism.
Now this last paper is a work in progress.
It's collaborative with Cailin, but also
with one of our graduate
students, Aydin Mohseni.
Okay, so the last models
considered social factors
as a ways in which people update
on evidence from other agents
and change their behavior
in light of the behavior of other agents
to explain how polarization can appear.
In this model, we're going
to look just at individuals
who are engaged in kind of
a Bayesian learning activity
based on a stream of data
generated by some outside source.
And we're gonna understand
this data generated
by the outside source
to represent information
that they receive from some media.
So you can think about this
as applying to different kinds of cases.
You can think about it
as applying to, you know,
traditional news media.
You could think about it as
applying to social media.
But the idea is that there's some process
by which the data that
they see is generated
by some intermediary.
That the data that they
see is somehow curated
by something between them and the world.
And the idea is that
there's a curation process
that involves some practice use, right?
So some processes involved
in choosing what data
of all the data that's sort of generated
in the world agents actually update on.
What we're gonna ask is how
those practices interact
with individual reasoning
biases to influence belies.
So here's the basic picture.
These media do not report
on all events in a domain.
Some events are selected for coverage.
So how do you choose
which events to cover?
Now, if you look at actual practice,
you look at norms for how
journalists should practice,
you see various criteria
described that are applied
to select which of the events
are gonna be reported on.
And so, just as an example,
it's a classic adage of a journalism.
You don't report on dog bites man,
you report on man bites dog, right?
So you report on the things
that are unusual or unexpected
or perhaps extreme events, right?
The biggest hurricane, you know,
the worst hurricane season,
you know, you don't report
on every earthquake, you
report on the ones that are
above a certain threshold
on the Richter scale.
Another example of a criteria
that might be applied.
The long-standing norm in journalism,
which in the US was actually
part of a official FCC policy
until the 1980s, that enjoins journalists
previously required
journalists to report fairly.
Now, this idea of a
fair reporting was given
a particular characterization.
The idea was that
if you ever reported on
some controversial matter,
you would need either within your story
or elsewhere within your organization
to also give equal time
to other sides of that issue.
So even to this day,
USA today for instance,
they run an editorial on
a controversial topic,
they always pair it
with an editorial supporting
the opposite position.
When you also see within
just regular articles,
an expectation that the
other side will be described
or will be given some, some
space to express their views.
Okay, so these are two different examples
of what I mean by criteria
that may be applied
to select which events are reported.
So how are we going to model this?
Well, here's the idea.
The idea is that there's some range
of events that occur in the world.
Think of it, maybe as storms
and the storms are sampled from
some normal distribution, W.
So you can think of the
severity of the storm
as just being something
that is randomly generated,
sampled from some random
variable distributed
according to this normal distribution.
W with fixed mean and
fixed standard deviation.
Now journalists aren't gonna
cover every storm that happens.
What they're gonna do is
they're going to select
from this initial distribution,
which events to cover
and you can think of this
as a process by which the
distribution W is transformed
into another distribution,
we to call a reported distribution, R
which generally differs from W.
Okay, and so now we have some
agents who are interested
in learning about how the world is,
but they're getting their
information from journalists.
And so what they're doing is
they're updating their beliefs
on data that's randomly sampled
from this new distribution
or the distribution of reported events.
And what we're interested in is
how does their posterior distribution,
how does the Bayesian agent's
beliefs about the world differ
from the distribution of actual events?
And in particular,
we're going to assume that
the underlying process,
we can take the agents to assume
that the underlying processes
IS Gaussian with unknown mean
and variance, they're going
to assume interchangeability
and what we're going to
is model their beliefs
with what's known as a normal
inverse gamma distribution.
Now, the important thing here is just,
that distribution allows them
to calculate an expected value
for the mean of W
and an expected value for
the standard deviation
or the variance of W
and what's gonna happen
is we're gonna be able
to compare those expected values
for the mean, and the variance
with the actual mean and variance of W.
Okay, and so we're gonna assume
that W is some normal distribution.
It's got some fixed mean and variance.
The mean mew in general can be off zero.
And so we're gonna assume
that there's some social neutral points.
Sort of what, you know,
what people take, you know,
what journalists I should say,
take to be the sort of common
knowledge about, you know,
where things are on average,
but the actual distribution
is going to be,
maybe deviate from that.
And now we're gonna consider
a few different processes
by which the reported
distribution R, is constructed.
So one hyperbole,
journalists just exaggerate.
So sometimes, so what happens
is, you know, X occurs.
They report some factor
H times X, you know,
it's the biggest storm,
the worst hurricane,
the biggest earthquake, even
if it isn't really the biggest.
Okay, and so we have some parameter H
that governs how that works.
Here's another process, extremity.
Journalists only report
on events that lies some
distance from the neutral point.
So this is again,
like I'm not gonna report
on every earthquake.
I'm only going to report on the ones
that exceed some value
on the Richter scale.
And then the final one is fair reporting
which I discussed before?
And the way that we're
gonna model that here is
that every time you have an event
that journalists wanna report on,
on one side of the neutral point,
they need to look for another event
that represents the other side.
So every time they report on one side,
they report on the other side as well.
Now they're always reporting real events.
They're just pairing them
in a way where every event
on one side corresponds
to an event on the other.
Now we're also, we also consider
distributions that result
from combining these.
We'll look at each of these individually,
we combine them in various ways.
Now, just to give you a
sense of what this does.
Each of these transformations
can be understood
to produce a distribution.
And so if we start with
our distribution W,
labeled here as the
objective distribution,
what hyperbole does is sort
of flatten that distribution,
but also shift its mean a little bit away
from the neutral point, zero.
What extremity bias does is it
just cuts out part of the events.
So not all of the events
are reported, just the tails
and then fair reporting does this thing
where you basically take
the part of the distribution
on each side of the neutral point
and you normalize it
so that the probability
of being on one side
or on the other is 0.5,
or that corresponds to
pairing these events.
But you do it in such
a way that you're only,
you're keeping the shape
of the distribution the
same, you're just rescaling
so that the total area
underneath the distribution,
to the left of zero is equal
to that to the right of zero.
So what sorts of results do we see here?
Well, an agent updating on
data sample from R convergences
to a posterior distribution
that approximates R.
So we're just approximating
each of these distributions
as a normal distribution.
On generally,
these are gonna differ
from the true distribution.
You can vat your error
with respect to the mean
or the variance, but you're gonna be able
to see these as a pretty
straightforward approximation
of the reported evidence.
So what you see then is that, well,
the way you get the most
reliable beliefs is just
by reporting on the true
distribution of evidence.
So here's just an example of this.
I'm sort of cognizant of time here.
I'm timing myself.
I've been going for 52 minutes,
but I started a little bit late
and I know that it's one now.
So I'm going to pick up
the pace a little bit here.
So here's an example of this.
You have some true
distribution of evidence.
You then have a reported
distribution of events,
combining some of these
different distortions.
And then you end up with some posterior.
This is the one on the, pink one here,
some posterior distribution
that approximates
with the normal distribution,
the reported evidence.
Okay, so now let's consider
the following addition
to this model.
We suppose that instead of updating
on all of the data that
journalists produce,
agents have a cognitive bias.
They have a tendency to prefer to update
on data that is consistent
with their existing beliefs.
So this is known as confirmation bias,
where individuals seek out evidence
that supports their existing beliefs,
and they ignore evidence
that conflicts with them,
or alternatively sometimes
they re-interpret evidence
that conflicts with their beliefs
as supporting their
beliefs when it doesn't.
So here's how we're gonna
implement this idea.
We're gonna suppose that
there's some probability
for any reported events
that the agent updates
on that event,
but that probability is
gonna be less than one.
And it's going to be a decreasing function
of the distance between data
and the agent's expectations
for the mean result.
So, one way of thinking
about this is the probability
of updating on data
that the agent thinks is very
likely is going to be higher
than the probability of updating
on data that the agent
thinks is very unlikely.
So what happens when we
introduced this modification?
Well, it turns out then with
this modification, once again,
based on very well-documented
psychological behavior
and real people, we get a very
different kind of outcome.
Now, what happens is instead
of trying to approximate
the whole distribution
of reported events with the Gaussian,
what we find is that
agents tend to converge
to a Gaussian centered at or near one
of the modes of their
reported distribution.
In particular, whichever mode is closest
to their prior expected mean.
So what this means is that
for bi-modal reported distributions
which can occur when
you have extremity bias
or when you have fair
and balanced reporting,
you can come up with situations.
You find situations where
agents that have priors
on one side converge to
the mode closest to them.
Whereas agents that have beliefs
on the other side converge
to the node that's closest to them.
And these are gonna generally be different
from one another.
And in fact, what you can
see is that over time,
beliefs can actually
diverge from one another.
Priors that are close to one
another can become more distant
with more data.
And the reason that happens is
even though the priors are
initially close to one another,
nonetheless one is closer to
one mode and the other closer
to the other mode, and
they approach the modes
of the report distribution.
Here's a figure that shows that happening.
You have some true
distribution of evidence.
You have here, some
combination of extremity bias
and a fair reporting that leads
to some distorted reported
distribution of evidence.
And what you find is in
these two different charts
on the right, the two pink ones,
agents that begin with
slightly different priors
where you see that in both
cases, their priors are,
you know, they're less certain
than they end up being, the priors,
the less opaque Gaussian.
You see is that although
they start kind of close
to one another, over time, they separate
and moreover, their confidence
becomes much greater.
I.e. their expected value
for the standard deviation
of the events in the
world becomes smaller.
And so neither agent ends up
approximating the true
distribution of events very well.
They both have smaller variants
in the true distribution
of events, and they get the mean wrong.
Okay, so this is the kind
of polarization, right?
It's a polarization where agents
with different priors presented
with the same evidence end
up with different posteriors
and what's driving this results is the way
that we've modeled confirmation
bias, along with the way
in which the evidence is presented.
What happens is in cases
where there's little
or no data that lies
between the two modes,
agents don't get pulled
towards the true central behavior, right?
So they never end up approximating W
because all they ever see
or all they ever actually
update on is data
that lies near one of the two modes.
Now, I think, you know,
it's not really the
point of the talk today.
I just wanna flag though,
one very interesting results
of this work is that hyperbole
which I think is arguably
the only of these biases
that we really consider
problematic, generally speaking,
or at least incompatible with
good journalistic practice,
actually doesn't
contribute to polarization,
unless you also have
fairness and extremity bias
and extremity bias, especially
to a lesser extent now fairness
do conform with journalistic norms.
I think that it's not
considered problematic
for journalists to report only on things
that are considered interesting
or novel or out of the ordinary.
Okay, so again, in the interest of time,
I'm gonna do this briefly,
but I'm gonna ask now,
what did these models
taken together tell us
about the real-world
phenomenon of polarization?
Which model is right?
Now, I think that there's a
attempting line of thought here.
Just to think about this sort of situation
in a way analogous to how you might think
about a scientific theory.
So the idea here is you
come up with some model,
that model reproduces some
qualitative phenomenon.
You might take that fact,
prima facie evidence
that some feature of the
model actually describes how,
or some aspect of how
say a social situation
or social group functions, right?
This is a move that's very similar
to a standard inferential pattern
often attributed to scientists
whereby if you have a theory
that makes some prediction.
Say about the outcomes of some experiment
or the tendency of some
phenomenon to occur,
and then you find that
that phenomenon occurs,
you infer that the theory
must be true or possible true
or you increase your credence
that that particular theory is accurate.
Now there's a well-known defeater
for this sort of reasoning
to the situation in which you
have, or sometimes called,
under discrimination
of theory by evidence.
That is you have many different theories
that are apparently equally compatible
with the observed data.
So in a case like that, if
you have different theories
that explain the data
and you don't have a way
of choosing between them, you might say,
well that undermines my
confidence in any of them.
And so you might think
that the right moral to draw from models
of the sort that I've just
discussed is that, look,
these models can't tell us anything
about how real world polarization works.
We can't infer anything from them.
They disagree about the
underlying mechanism.
They provide different explanations.
And that means that we
can't choose between them.
And if we can't choose between them,
that means that we can't, for instance,
use them to make any kinds
of policy recommendations.
We can't use them to
think about, you know,
how we got into a particular
epistemic situation
and how we might get out of it.
We can't use them to reason effectively
about the world as we find it.
And so you might think then
that really what we need
to understand real world
polarization is something,
something very different.
So maybe some combination
of fine-grained empirical evidence,
something that can really
distinguish these cases
from one another,
help us understand what's really going on.
Now, maybe there's still a
role for models of the sort
or perhaps actually successor
models that are, you know,
attempt to model the world
with greater detailed accuracy
because then you might think,
well what the models can do is come up
with more specific and
discriminating predictions
that we could then use to distinguish
between the possible explanations
of polarization presented
by each of these models.
Now, I wanna suggest
that that is not at all
the right moral to draw
from the situation.
That in fact, we can draw much stronger
and more important morals
from the models as presented.
Why is that?
Well, the kind of dialectic I
just presented seems to take
for granted that if these models disagree
about the underlying
cause of polarization,
then they are incompatible, right?
And this is the sort of thing
you might think to be true
if you're talking about,
say theories in physics where
different theories, you know,
if you have two different
theories of the electron,
you might think only one
of them can be right.
And so if both of them
reproduce the data you have,
you don't have a way of
choosing between them,
even though you know only
one of them could be correct,
but that's not what's going on here.
It's not the case
that these different
mechanisms are incompatible.
Rather, I think what we see here is
that there are apparently
multiple sufficient causes
for the social phenomenon of polarization.
Now, as I said at the beginning,
I don't at all mean to suggest
that what I've given here
is an exhaustive list
or even the most important examples
of possible causes of polarization.
I just claim that these
are models that suggest
that a certain kind
of mechanism may be
sufficient for polarization,
but all of these mechanisms
can be present together, right?
It can be that we have confirmation bias.
In fact, it appears we
do have confirmation bias
and it may be that we
have conformity bias.
And in fact, it appears we
do have conformity bias.
And it may be that we
tend to trust some sources
of evidence more than others,
perhaps we condition based
on the epistemic success
of the originator of the evidence,
which apparently is
something that we do do.
So all of these can be
operative at the same time.
Now, what that means is that
even if you had more
fine-grained empirical data
and predictions that tried to distinguish
between the different models,
the fact that you could get good evidence
that one of these mechanisms is present
and is leading to
polarization, does not imply
that the other ones are not also present
and also contributing to polarization.
So, in fact, I think that the right way
of thinking about what's going on here is
that we see that evidence for
a particular hypothesis here
about what causes polarization
isn't evidence against other alternative.
You might've thought competing,
but in fact complimentary
explanations of polarization.
And so I take that to be the basis
for a strong cautionary note,
but how to think about
policy making intended
to somehow ameliorate polarization,
particularly say polarization
and social media.
The idea is that policy
interventions tend to focus
on unitary explanations of the phenomenon.
There are some positive cause,
some idea that if you
intervene on that cause
through policymaking, say changing the way
that algorithms can work on Facebook,
changing the way that Twitter works,
number of Twitter followers
someone can have, whatever.
That by intervening on
that particular variable,
you're going to have some
clear impact, influence
on the thing that you're trying to change,
in this case polarization.
But if it's true
that there are multiple
mutually compatible,
independently sufficient
possible causes for polarization
and it's not clear
that any single explanation
is going to suffice.
And that means that policy interventions
that target a single cause are
not only unlikely to succeed
on their own, but may even backfire
because what you need to be attentive
to is the way in which,
by trying to block one mechanism,
which is actually present,
you can unwittingly
amplify another mechanism
which is also present.
Just as an example, suppose
you're the sort of person
that thinks that conformity
and just you know,
poor connections between
different networks of people.
This is, Priya mentioned,
the filter bubble idea,
but that's basically what's going on
on this sort of proposal.
The idea would be well, what's
going on is that you have,
you know, people
sometimes say red internet
and a blue internet.
Republican's see some
things when they go online.
Democrats see other things
when they go online.
They're updating on different stuff.
They're conforming with different groups
and it's by sort of separating those
that you end up with polarization.
And so if we increased
the connections, right.
Showed more Democrats,
more Republican media
and showed more Republicans,
more Democratic media,
you might think what's gonna happen is
you're gonna have some convergence.
Well, it couldn't be that conformity
and these network effects
are playing a role,
but nonetheless, trust dynamics
is also playing a role.
In which case, by exposing more,
exposing people more to the other side,
if they distrust the other side enough
that they're not gonna make any difference
or may under some circumstances
even make people tend to polarize more.
For instance using something like, well,
under some modifications
of the trust dynamics can
actually lead them to polarize more.
And so what this means
practically speaking is
that empirical work
cannot be directed only
to positively identifying a
specific causal factors, right?
Not only to showing that
some factor is operative
in some contexts, but also
to establishing what other
factors are also operative
and to weighing the
relative causal contribution
of the possibly many
different causal factors.
This is a much more
difficult kind of activity
and something that I
think it's very, you know,
we don't have great
methods to my knowledge
of establishing this
kind of relative amount of significance.
But it seems to me that
in a situation like this
where we have multiple sufficient causes
for a social phenomenon
and some reason to think
that all of them may be
present and may be important,
this is what we need
to figure out how to do
in order to be able to properly evaluate
any kind of policy proposal
that is gonna be successfully sensitive
to the full complexity of the situation.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, James.
That was absolutely fantastic.
And so I would like to invite everyone
to unmute and clap, yes.
Much to think about.
So if I may, before opening
up the floor to questions,
ask you one myself.
I was just, I mean, I really
like your caution showing
that there are many
ways to think about it,
but that we need to really be cautious
about concluding that
there's one simple solution
or that we have captured
the under, you know,
the actual real world
polarization adequately
with any of these models
to really chase off the
one solution or the other.
I think I wanted to
come back to this issue
that you did raise in the beginning
and bring in the work of Dan Kahan
who is at the Center for
Cultural Cognition at Yale.
Well, you know, that he's
been studying as, you know,
the sort of disbelief
in climate change and science denialism.
So it sounds like, you know,
this landscape of priors
that people have that, you know,
these are informed by very,
by our tribal identities
and they are part and parcel
of a larger worldview.
So one of the things he,
his findings often show
that there are sort of
these two broadish mindsets,
sort of a more collectivist mindset
and a more individualist mindset.
And that this mindset is
independent of one's position
on any one particular
issue that is a broad lens
with which people see the whole world.
And therefore then every
issue gets refracted
through that lens.
So I was very curious, you know,
in these modeling approaches,
you obviously had room
for priors and stuff, but
I was curious, what can,
if anything be done about what seems
like a fundamental,
psychological, sociological schism
between personality
types that is, you know,
very historically, culturally,
politically rooted.
And you know, the same sort
of simplistic arguments
have been about, you know,
east versus west, collective
versus individual, et cetera.
So I was very curious how
you would see that kind of,
you know, broader view of the
world, institutions, people,
et cetera, being folded into thinking
about how it sort of
manifests in polarization.
- So I think I have
maybe two things to say.
One is that I see it as a kind
of yes and sort of situation
where I think, you know,
each of the kinds of mechanisms
that I pointed to you,
there's psychological
evidence that we engage
in this sort of behavior,
that we do differentially
trust evidential sources,
that we do prefer to conform.
There's psychological
evidence to support this idea
of background either ideologies
or perhaps even something more basic
about how we think about the world, right?
I mean, I think sometimes
in this literature, it's not totally clear
that you can distinguish a case
where it's culturally constructed
and ideological and people
are sort of subscribed
to a set of beliefs and
the case where people
actually self sort based on the strength
of their discussed reaction.
I mean, so you see papers like
this saying, well you know,
conservatives tend to have a
stronger discussed reaction
or tend to have different
kinds of reactions
to fear or to outsiders.
It's sort of, it's hard to know
I think at this stage,
other people may know more,
but it's hard for me to know at this stage
whether we should think of that
as cultural or innate across individuals.
But once again, it's something that
even if that weren't there,
other aspects of human
psychology seem to be sufficient
to explain polarization, right?
And so if we focus all of our attention
on trying to sort of solve
this underlying tribalistic
sort of tendency, I think that we're going
to miss other things that
are probably also mattering.
That's one thing.
The second thing is that I have,
Cailin and I have another paper together
where we push back against
some of these ideas
that the right way of explaining
political tribalism is
via some organizing
principle like ideology
which isn't exactly the same
as what you're describing,
but it's closely related.
And so George Lakoff, for instance,
at Berkeley has this idea
that there are two basic ideologies,
the nurturing mother and the strict father
and everyone falls into one or the other.
So when you disagree about gun control
or you disagree about, you know, COVID,
you aren't disagreeing about those things,
you're disagreeing about
whether you, you know,
the state should be a nurturing
mother or a strict father.
And we suggest that
there are some examples
where there appear to be
correlations between values
or beliefs that aren't
really clearly explained
by this kind of ideological explanation
unless the ideology becomes so vague
that really anything can be
associated with either of them.
- Right, but I guess, but also
you know, there's a tendency,
right, especially in Western epistemology
to be very reductive and
have like dichotomies,
always break things into dichotomies.
So it's like, you know,
it's either this or that.
And there's like nothing sort
of interrelating in between.
So there's that problem as
well with that position,
as well as what you are suggesting is a,
so there's a deeper problem
with those kinds of positions
that are very reductionist
in some way, right,
reducing everything to--
- So what I would say though,
is I mean, so what we do
in this paper is we show
that actually you can arrive
at similar kinds of correlations
between beliefs with a
kind of trust dynamics
where there's no organizing principle,
it's entirely indogenous.
You get epistemic factions
where you have a whole bunch
of different beliefs,
totally unrelated beliefs
but where agents sort of clump.
You know, you've got all
the ones who believe action,
you know, who prefer actions A, A prime,
A double prime, A triple prime,
even though they're totally unrelated.
And then the ones that prefer B,
and B prime and B double prime and so on,
without needing to introduce any kind
of organizational principle
or background ideology
or anything to sort of, it
just happens via a process
where you know, I agree
with you on gun control,
so I'm gonna trust your
views about climate change.
And I agree with you about that,
so I'm gonna trust your views about COVID.
And one example that we point to is,
and this is controversial,
but I really liked the
example is, you know,
last March hydroxychloroquine became
the conservative treatment for COVID
and Remdesivir became the
liberal treatment for COVID
at a a point where there was,
far before there was clear evidence on it.
So you sort of, you see
this kind of people sorting
into beliefs about matters
of fact that appear
to depend on their background, you know,
other background views, but in a way,
I don't see any meaningful sense
in which hydroxychloroquine
is the strict father solution
to COVID and Remdesivir is
the nurturing mother solution
to COVID or the collective
versus anti collectivist one.
It seems like this is just
something random happened,
but they sorted.
- So we have, let me see,
you can hear me, right.
Okay, so we have a question
from Sanjeev Kumar on the chat.
Do you think polarization per
se may not be problematic,
but the fact that we have
not developed a framework
that can rationalize a pursuit
for an underlying unity of things.
We don't say that our legs are polarized.
- So I think there are two
separate sorts of issues here.
One is whether or not polarization
is by itself problematic.
And I think there are
good reasons to think
that polarization is not
by itself problematic,
especially if polarization
is in some way transient.
I think that there are
very good reasons to think
that one reason why you
might have mechanisms
that slow down learning
and maybe preserve
transient polarization is
because it can take a
long time to get reliable,
consistent, representative
data about the world.
And, you know, a situation where you have,
for instance different cultural groups
or even different individuals
performing different
practices and learning
from those practices is one perhaps
where you can expect to achieve
better overall outcomes over time.
And so you might think
that some of the mechanisms
that lead to polarization
are actually mechanisms
that over the very long
run benefit social learning
or benefit cultural evolution
or something like that
and may even have been, you know,
in some sense selected for.
So I don't think polarization
by itself is necessarily problematic.
The idea though, that
some of these, you know,
really quite dichotomous
situations, these propositions
where there's a lot of evidence.
And yet nonetheless, there
seems to be a very long
and apparently quite
damaging disagreement.
I don't wanna think, I don't tend to think
that the right way of thinking
about such situations is
one where there really are
just two ways of being
in the world and they're equally right.
Or, you know, in a way suggested
by this idea that our
legs are not polarized.
Our legs are chiral.
I mean, I guess that's a
different, physics joke.
- Any other questions,
please feel free to
type them into the chat.
Wait, I have another question.
So I will again, take the
liberty James, to ask you.
So I wondered whether you found
that for particular issues,
some models were better descriptors.
I'm not talking about the
solutions, because I mean,
I think I totally take
your point that, you know,
it would be just too simplistic
to just say that, okay,
this is the model,
and therefore these are all the solutions
that can describe how to
mitigate the polarization.
But I was curious.
So for example, if you took
sort of the polarization
on the issue of vaccination, for example,
versus climate change.
Did you find in the
modeling approach that,
you know, one set of models
was like a better descriptor
of the problem?
Because I think that's the
point that you're trying
to make that it's very hard to figure out
and restrict ourselves
to one unique model,
but I wondered if there
were particular kinds.
You know, I'm just trying
to see if there are ways
to map particular issues
to particular kinds of agent models.
And whether you found that,
whether there's something there
that you found interesting for, you know,
for matters that have to do
with, you know, personal being,
you know, like a medical
issue, which has to do
with our personhood, much
more immediate salience
than climate change, which
for many people feels
like it's quite distanced
because they are not accepting
that it has touched us
in our lives already.
So I was just curious
about like the proximity
and you know, what are the
other kinds of beliefs?
What are the beliefs can
be classified in some way
in terms of particular model
being a better descriptor?
- So to an extent, I mean,
I wanna emphasize again, that
the models here are so simple
that I'm reluctant to confidently assert
that what's going on in
any of these models is
what's going on in any
particular real-world case.
That said, I do think
that some of the qualitative
features of the models do seem
to invoke particular
cases particularly well.
And so for instance, one
of the things that happens
in the conformity model is
that you have a trade off
between how much you care
about successful action
and how much you care about conformity.
Now, normally when we present
the model, we think about it
in terms of the strength of
your preference to conform.
But another sort of dual way
of thinking about it is the weakness
of the benefits of performing
the successful action.
And so there are some
sorts of cases where,
although there is a matter of fact
and there is a lot of evidence available,
nonetheless as an individual,
the decisions you make aren't going
to have particularly
strong effects one way
or the other, even you
know, there's polarization
in the US regarding evolutionary theory.
Again, it's a case where
there's an enormous amount
of evidence available,
but there's absolutely
nothing that hurt like,
there's no way in which
you're individually hurt
going around and doing
things as an individual
that are incompatible
with evolutionary theory,
which for most people just mean saying,
I don't believe in
evolutionary theory, right?
That doesn't harm you in some way,
but you do get the benefits perhaps,
in conforming within your community.
Climate change is a bit like
that because the consequences
of your actions tend to be
remote in space and time.
But other things like, you know,
it's harder to see some of
the behaviors we've seen
around COVID as an example
of that kind of behavior.
On the other hand, I mean,
Cailin and I actually
considered, we didn't do it.
We considered writing an op-ed describing
how COVID perhaps reflected
just a complete failure
of classical decision theory,
where you think that you can,
you know, that people are
motivated by immediate benefits
or harms, and so sort
of directly seeing this
kind of behavior led to
these kinds of outcomes
for these kinds of people
who are close to me.
I see a directly that
would affect your behavior.
But that, in fact, it
seems like other sorts
of considerations could counterbalance
that kind of direct,
immediate evidence, right.
Especially now, right?
I mean maybe last March
or April or May, you know,
you're not in New York,
you're not in Paris.
You know, maybe you don't trust
what's your hearing about,
but by now, I think people have
much more direct experience
and yet many people still are,
act as if they're very skeptical.
- So we have a question from Jenny Wagner.
Is the timing of the update
of information for each
agent a critical issue.
Imagine you update information
of the agents asynchronously.
Would that change the behavior
of the entire network?
- So there are a few different
kinds of effects here.
One has to do with how often
agents perform their action
before sharing evidence, right?
So you can think about this
as how large a sample do you collect
before stopping and your beliefs, right?
Because when that's large,
you know, you're gonna go
with what you originally
think is the better action.
You're gonna gather a lot of data
and then you're gonna reconsider.
And you can think of that
as a kind of asynchronous updating
because you aren't updating
every time you gather evidence.
You're updating only
after a certain amount
of evidence has been
gathered by each agent.
And that absolutely
changes the various things
in the models.
It doesn't change the qualitative effects
that these are the kinds of outcomes.
And sometimes you get this
and sometimes you get that,
but it does change things
like the rate of which agents learn,
which outcomes are more
likely, things like that.
Other kinds of asynchronous
learning might involve things
like only sharing every so often
even though you're updating more often
or some agents share
and other agents don't.
One thing that we look at as a situation
where only some agents are
able to gather information.
And so some agents are updating only
on evidence gathered by others.
We treat that as a situation
where say you have some policymakers
and you have some scientists
and the policy makers are updating
on the scientist's evidence.
And all of those sorts of
things can have an effect.
But they, I think at
the level of description
that I've given here,
they don't matter to any of
the results that I've reported.
- Great, so there's one other
question from Tyler Lutes
who is a former Franke fellow.
Polarization might also
be socially advantageous
in situations in which
truth itself, for instance,
the relative success of A
versus B changes with time.
Do you have a sense
of how your models behave in
such dynamic circumstances?
I have in mind here climate
change in particular
in which most of us believe
that true distribution
of climactic phenomenon is
changing right before our eyes.
- So I think that the
answer, so we haven't looked
at situations where the
actual success rates change.
I mean, it's an interesting
modification to the model,
but one that we haven't looked at.
Kevin Goldman though, in
one of his earliest papers
on network epistemology, really
emphasized the importance
of what he called transient
diversity of beliefs.
But you might think also
as transient polarization,
you know, and I mentioned this
in response to a previous
comment early on.
Oh no, to an earlier question,
the idea that under some circumstances,
polarization may actually be beneficial.
And so Kevin's suggestion
there is that basically,
if instead of thinking of the,
a situation where the
actual outcomes change,
if you think about a
situation where over time,
you you get access to new or
different kinds of evidence.
Having people who
continue to hold the thing
that seems incompatible
with the old evidence means
that they'll sort of pursue
new lines of evidence.
And the example that he
gives is the discovery
of the bacterial origins of ulcers.
And so it turns out
that there's a bacterium called H. Pylori
that causes ulcers.
By the 1960s, the idea of a
bacterial cause of ulcers was
basically ruled out by a series of,
really a small number of
very influential experiments
that claim to have shown
that the stomach is antibacterial.
Basically, that there
aren't bacterial cultures
in the stomach, and so you can't have
a bacterial cause of ulcers.
And, you know, one of the, you know,
people stopped pursuing
that line of research except
in Australia, where they
were just disconnected enough
from the rest of the research community.
They had their own
sort of autonomous research program going,
and they continued to
explore this possibility
and eventually identified
a kind of bacteria
that hadn't been known before.
And, you know, we were able
to establish that in fact,
that is present in stomachs.
And in fact it does
cause ulcers, you know,
and the guy who would ultimately--
- I was gonna say, this is a famous case
where the experimenter actually took--
- Drank H. Pylori.
- Yeah, drank the H. Pylori.
- Then took an antibiotic.
So he gave himself an
ulcer by drinking H. Pylori
and the cured it with antibiotics.
And it's not clear what
the epistemic value
of that is, but it's (mumbles).
- I think desperation science, right.
To persuade.
So I guess if there are
no further questions,
I would really like to thank James
for an excellent thought-provoking talk.
And we really look forward
to the discussion tomorrow
with Professor Weatherall and Kevin Dorst.
So at this point, I just want
to invite everyone to unmute
and clap if possible.
- Thank you Priya.
- Thank you so much.
- [James] Look forward
to seeing you tomorrow.
- See you all tomorrow
again at 3:00 PM, thank you.
Actually, before I close,
I realized that I'd wanted
to do this at the beginning.
Today is the first anniversary
of George Floyd's death.
So I just wanted us to
remember that in closing.